most pathetic human being things are
getting ugly in the kardashian-jenner
house and we get to watch it all because
the mid-season teaser trailer for
Keeping Up with the Kardashians just
dropped and it is all kinds of drama the
rest of the season has so many crazy
things going on in fact it appears there
is a divide within the normally United
fam I feel like the really funny side of
you guys outweighed the mean side and I
feel like it's gotten a little mean girl
it's not doing this this is cruel as
much as I love you you fight a lot
dirtier than you used to fight and from
the looks of it Chris has a reason to be
worried just tune in Kim and Kourtney
seemed to be at odds over a candy land
theme party and after court calls her
sister this Kim fires back with this but
it doesn't seem like Kourt is too
concerned
in fact the mother of three says she
wouldn't care if the show ended
yeah when et caught up with keeping up
executive producer Ryan Seacrest in May
he had this to say about the rumors that
Courtney was ready to throw in the towel
honestly I don't know how they do it
they've lived for over a decade with
cameras following I could not do it no
matter what they were paying them I
couldn't do it so I give them a lot of
credit from those cameras in their lives
all the time and I love you Courtney but
back to the trailer the intense fighting
is getting to Chris and Courtney
everything is so different I don't know
why we can't all just respect each other
I think sometimes there's a lot of
judgment I feel like we just need to
press a reset button you guys got to get
back to the fact that we're just family
but the beef between the girls isn't the
only source of drama
according to Chloe she received a pretty
lavish gift from her ex Tristan Thompson
gave me last night
of course Chloe and the NBA star split
in February amid his cheating scandal
with Kylie's former bestie Jordan Woods
Chloe recently opened up about putting
their differences aside for the sake of
their daughter true on J Shetty's on
purpose podcast I want to show my
daughter that it's okay and it's a
beautiful thing to also forgive her dad
he's a great person it's you know maybe
him and I weren't compatible or whatever
on that way but that's okay like
nobody's gonna die here and I always
want true to be surrounded by love and I
know babies feel energy we feel energy
and I just want her to always feel just
bliss as much as I can
oh how we can't wait to see all this
play out you never know what's gonna
happen
you